字幕: Takahiro Shimpo
校正: Takafusa Kitazume
皆さんは最近「失敗」をしましたか？
失敗するのは誰だって嫌ですよね
僕の場合は12年間
短距離の選手として
自分の体力の限界に
挑んできたということもあり
何か新しいこと、難しいことに
チャレンジするのが大好き
チャレンジすることで味わえる
ドキドキ感、ワクワク感
そして 自分が頑張ってるっていう
実感が大好きなんです
だからその分
たくさん失敗を経験してきました
例えば
幻の生物ユニコーンがいると聞いて
ラオスという国に一人で
旅に出掛けましたが
ユニコーンはおらず それどころか
ホテルのおじさんにお金を
ぼったくられましたし
趣味のジョギングでは
距離を伸ばそうと思って
新しい道を開拓していたら
完全に道に迷い
膝を故障してしまいました
「なんで こんなことに
なったんだろうな？」
と思うことはしょっちゅうあります
では どのようにして
それらの失敗を乗り越えてきたのか
それは 僕の失敗に対する考え方に
秘訣があると思います
そして それは
失敗した時こそ 自分を褒める
なんです
このような考え方を持ったきっかけが
二年前のタイ・バンコクでの交換留学
将来はグローバルに活躍したい
このようなやる気に満ちて
当初は留学に望みましたが
蓋を開けてみると
タイなのに日本人どころか
アジア人は僕 クラスに一人だけ
しかも 周りのクラスメイトたちは
みな ネイティブ並みのスピードで
英語を話してくる
そんな状況の中
僕は英語での間違いが恐くて
なかなかクラスメイトたちと
上手く話すことができませんでした
例え話したとしても
ちょっとした発音ミス
ちょっとした文法ミスを
自分ですぐに責めてしまって
より話せなくなってしまう
悪循環に陥っていました
そんなある日のこと
クラスメイトたちが
その夜のパーティーについて
盛り上がっているのを聞いて
僕はあることに気がついたんです
それは 完璧だと思っていた
彼らの英語が
実は間違いだらけだったということ
中には昨日の話をしているのに
現在形で話している人もいました
でも それでも彼らは
堂々と自分の言いたいことを発言して
お互いに盛り上がっていた
それを見て 僕はこう思ったんです
「失敗してもいいんだ
むしろ外国で外国語を使う
そんな状況だったら
失敗すること、間違えることが
多くて当然
だったら それを責めるよりも
そのチャレンジを評価しようじゃないか」
外国で外国語を使う
つまり 慣れないこと
新しいことにチャレンジした時は
人は誰だって間違えたり
失敗するのが多くて当然
だったら その失敗を責めるんじゃなくて
その努力を、そのチャレンジを
まずは褒めてあげようじゃないか
このように思ったんです
すると 不思議なことに
英語で話すことが
恐くなくなっていきました
また 例え英会話中に
間違いを犯したとしても
「よっしゃ 今 俺間違えた
この間違えを直せば
まだまだ俺はレベルアップできる」
と自分に言い聞かせることによって
その間違いを引きずることがなくなり
そこから新しく何かを
学び取ろうという姿勢に
切り替えることができました
具体的にはその間違えたところを
即座にメモしておき
寝る前だったり
休み時間に確認をする
これを繰り返すことで
自分の英語にも自信がつき
友達が増えるきっかけになりました
気づいたら
周りを巻き込んで
国際交流パーティーを企画している
積極的な自分がいました
「翔太は本当に半年間で変わったな」
「どうやったら そこまで変われるんだ？」
「驚いたよ」
このような言葉をクラスメイトから
もらった時は
心から嬉しかったです
勿論 僕のチャレンジは
まだまだ続きます
今 僕が将来
やってみたいと思っていることは
ビジネスの力を使って
新しい教育の場を創り
それを運営していくこと
学生、教師、そして地域の
三方向がそれぞれメリットを持てる
三方良しの教育モデルを創り
それを世界にも広めていきたい
勿論 その過程には
多くの失敗、多くの間違いが
あると思います
でも 僕はそれをマイナスには捉えません
なぜならば どんな失敗
どんな間違いだって
最終的に成功してしまえば
一つの経験
一つの学びとなるのです
だからこそ
小さな失敗に一喜一憂することなく
そのチャレンジを評価していきたい
そして 自分自身の大きな志を
つかみ取りたいと思います
さて 今回のTEDx のテーマは
ファーストストーリー
ここにいる皆さん方も
何か新しいことにチャレンジされる方
多いと思います
その過程で何かに躓いたり
何かに失敗したな と思った時は
自分を責めるのではなくて
まず自分を褒めてみてください
それが 難しいと思われる方は
意識的に笑顔を作ってみてください
ちょっと皆さんでやってみましょうか
皆さん その場に座ったままで結構ですので
思いっきり口角を上げて
イーっと笑顔を作ってみてください
イーっと
(笑)
ちょっと緊張してますかね？
ちょっと皆さん まだ緊張してますかね？
でも とにかく
今度は笑顔を作ってみたら
少し胸を張って
目線を少し高くしてみてください
お上手ですね
ありがとうございます
どうですか？
皆さん ちょっと前向きな
気分になりませんか？
形から入ることで
気分が前向きになると思います
それを続けていけば
考え方も少しずつ
変わってくると思います
結果としてそれが
次のチャレンジに対する
前向きな姿勢に繋がると思います
ですので 今 皆さんがやったことを
是非 失敗したなと思った時
やってみてください
失敗するのは
誰だって恐いことです
僕だって恐いです
でも 失敗こそが
チャレンジをした、努力をしたという
何よりの証だと思います
そして 失敗しないことが
重要ではなくて
失敗から何を学び
そして それを次にどう繋げるか
これが大事だと思います
だからこそ
失敗した時こそ 自分を褒めてみてください
僕もこの後は控え室に帰った後
思いっきり自分を褒めて
次のチャレンジを楽しみたいと思います
ありがとうございました
(拍手)